well Russia has launched another wave of
missile attacks across Ukraine killing
at least seven people and injuring many
more Kiev says the strikes were mainly
directed at Power and heating facilities
that with winter arriving as much of the
nation sees its first significant
snowfall
President Vladimir zielinski says more
than 10 million ukrainians are currently
without electricity
I'd like to get straight across to DW's
correspondent Janet Phillips Schultz
joining me now from Kiev how are you and
the residents of Kiev being impacted by
these power outages
there's still regular power Cuts all
over the city until major power provider
just said that the grid is still running
on less than half of the normal capacity
um this I'm in a privileged situation of
course here in the hotel we have a
generator but a lot of ukrainians most
ukrainians of course don't have this
kind of luxury at at home and a big
problem is that electricity means much
more than light it can affect a lot of
vital services like running water and
especially now of course that the winter
sets in heating is the biggest problem a
lot of ukrainians rely on electricity
for their for hitting their homes either
because of the the central heating
system is too weak or it's non-existent
so there are really a lot of problems
ahead for the city and the whole country
so it's not just difficult but dangerous
and yet Russia is blaming this suffering
on Ukraine itself because it won't come
to the negotiating table at this stage
in the war do you see any indication
that people there in Ukraine would be
interested in peace talks
I've asked the same question to many
people here in Kiev and the answer is
always a clear no a colleague of mine
said he doesn't know a single person in
Ukraine that wants to negotiate with
Russia at the moment and I think this is
truly the case here in the in the
country
government spokesperson just said that
he thinks Russia is trying to use the
same methods as terrorists harming
innocent people to have their demands
met and he also added that he's quite
sure that by destroying civilian
infrastructure not a single Ukrainian
will come to the negotiating table
and so as we go on in these cold winter
months how is the Ukrainian government
planning to address this crisis
well the government says that more than
1 000 Specialists are working around the
clock to repair the infrastructure and
of course there are also restrictions on
on consumers but the big problem is that
with every attack it gets more and more
difficult to find the equipment to
repair the infrastructure and the
government of course says the best
method is prevention and prevention in
this case means more air defense
assistance so that the missiles that are
targeted at the infrastructure can be
intercepted
is our correspondent Jan Phillip Schultz
reporting from Kiev thank you so much
for the update
well Mike Martin is war studies senior
visiting fellow at King's College London
my colleague asked him how Ukraine's
allies can help the millions who are now
without power in Ukraine
it's very difficult if not impossible
which is why probably why the Russians
are doing it
um what's happening is that the
infrastructure of the power grid
substations transmitters transmission
lines as well as some power generation
are being hit and damaged and obviously
this infrastructure takes years to build
in many cases so what the ukrainians are
going to be able to do is is repair
small parts of it and it is possible to
provide pin prick power in places like
hospitals by using generators but the
vast mass of the population uh 10
million people president zielinski said
I'm afraid it's going to be a winter
largely without power for many of them
Mike Martin speaking to us earlier now
even as they continue attacking civilian
infrastructure Russian troops have
retreated from several Ukrainian
territories and that they had occupied
for much of the year the DW's Matthias
bolingo went to the town of volcansk
near hafik Kiff rather just four
kilometers from the Russian border the
invading troops there are gone but they
have left Devastation behind them
it used to take less than two hours to
drive from kharkif to wolfchonsk now it
takes five you have to take small local
roads and long detours all the major
routes and bridges are destroyed
which is four kilometers from the border
with Russia
the town was taken on the first day of
the war Lucas tell us the Russians set
up a torture chamber in this Factory
they mostly took young men there Sergio
novalov says soldiers ordered him to go
there after they caught him outside
after curfew
I thought they would torture me as well
I came as I was told at 8 am but they
just made me dig trenches carry stuff
around and stack sandbags
I had to be there at eight and would
work until five that's how they made me
slave away
everything looks broken and the Russians
still show from across the border
the people who are still here will soon
face a tough winter the electricity is
often out and there's no gas for heating
some humanitarian Aid does come but not
often it's so hard to get there
given these conditions not everybody is
Happy the Russians are gone
here we could
formally there was work and we were
getting humanitarian Aid every 10 days
they would also hand out money now we
have nothing
excuse me
there's not much for sale at the market
and not many people
many left for Russia with the retreating
soldiers it's an area long considered
pro-russian now the ukrainians are in
charge again many are anxious and
suspicious
the painter says collaborators says a
woman she won't be on camera
mistrust is everywhere soldiers in
charge of the Town worry that locals are
informing the Russians
we hear about those who are working with
both sides they used to tip off the
Russians now they come to see us and say
this or that person was a collaborator
foreign
prepare for winter
his wife and young daughter out of town
and will soon join them
but he's determined to return
and hopes the town can get back to
normal
we're on our soil we didn't attack
anybody we don't want anything else
come on
more selling this is what the days are
like in wolfchonsk